hey I have a good news for you from the
world of science and reason georgian
college which is a college in ontario
canada has canceled their diploma in the
bogus pseudoscience of homeopathy after
the program started to receive more and
more criticism because of course
homeopathy has no place in colleges and
universities the georgia georgian
college put out a statement where they
said quote in light of the recent
response from our local community and
beyond and in consideration of our
students georgian college has made the
decision to cancel the homeopathy
program there's been a huge uproar
actually from the medical community
about this program and from the CBC's
coverage of this they wrote quote dr.
Chris Gore chevre an emergency medicine
physician sent letters of protest to the
college and to the provincial government
after seeing an advertisement for the
program which would have been offered at
the nearby campus in Barrie Ontario he
worried there would be a risk to public
health if people assumed homeopathy has
some legitimacy it gave me some angst
about the whole thing he said gorsh f is
already seeing evidence of homeopathy
'he's impact in his hospitals emergency
room we see people they have the flu and
they're sick and i asked did you get a
flu shot and they say my homeopath gave
me a flu shot and i think well you
didn't actually get anything now i know
that there are many people in our
audience who don't know that homeopathy
is a scam lots of people consider it
sort of the same as herbal remedies for
example which can mean many different
things when you even say herbal remedies
homeopathy is a non science right some
people call it pseudoscience I call it
non science it comes from the 18th
century and the concept is you take
substances and you dilute them
extensively huge huge huge dilution like
taking a spoonful of something and
putting it in Lake Michigan and stirring
it up and saying here drink a cup of
this that's often an analogy that's used
homeopathy is not herbal medicine
because herbal medicines whether or not
they work contain ingredients and the
concept of homeopathy
is such dilution of whatever so-called
ingredient is
there that there is effectively no
active ingredient in much of homeopathy
and you can usually only measure the
inactive ingredients like the sugar in
the little pills that they give you
homeopathy has no effect it cannot treat
or cure any symptoms or diseases and in
more and more countries it actually has
to be labeled that way and it does bum
me out because I believe I who believe
in this stuff they believe in homeopathy
they believe in Reiki Reiki is a special
one
people get tricked into thinking Reiki
as some ancient healing art it was
invented in 1922 right and I find it
fascinating that like for Reiki for
example the concept is one that appeals
to the non-religious but it's kind of
based on the same principles as religion
Reiki is based on the idea that you're
moving energy around through your hands
to heal people and improve symptoms
provide pain relief whatever and you
don't even need to know what symptoms
the person has just putting your hands
over the person Wow will have the energy
find the ailment that's similar to the
idea of a soul right which is a
religious idea the idea of some
invisible life force that goes beyond
knowledge and physiology and anyway
homeopathy Reiki it's mostly harmless
except I guess to your wallet when you
start spending money on this stuff
except when people go to this stuff
instead of real treatments for medical
issues that can actually harm them and I
understand being skeptical of the profit
mode of a wealth of Western medicine I'd
get that but just because you're
skeptical of the profit motive doesn't
mean you go to reiki and homeopathy you
know yeah and it's also a problem
because Georgian College is a public
university too so the taxpayers in
Canada are paying for this did anyone
think if you know you want to go to a
private organization to learn about
homeopathy or make up religious studies
as long as there's no fraud involved but
the fact that taxpayers are footing the
bill that's a problem absolutely
inappropriate this is a completely the
right decision and I know there are
people online who are mad with George
and college saying no this is a public
service it's great that they were
actually doing this blah blah blah it
has no place there it has absolutely no
place there